alright only on CBS this morning we have
more of our conversation with CIA
director Mike Pompeo the former
Republican congressman was one of
President Trump's first appointees the
two men meet nearly every day in the
Oval Office
Pompeyo spoke with us at CIA
headquarters we asked about the
intelligence community's relationship
with the White House and whether the
president takes allegations of Russian
election meddling seriously make no
mistake about it we have we're doing
things today that the sale was not doing
a year ago and there's more risk
attached to those risk taking that
sounds like you're expanding covert and
clandestine operations almost certainly
to what effect what do you want I want
the president to have the best
intelligence in the world as America's
top spy master CIA director Mike Pompeo
splits his time between the agency he
runs in Langley Virginia and the White
House where he personally helps deliver
the president's Daily Brief
what's that like take us behind the
scenes so sometimes each morning someone
hollers Pompeo you're in and I along
with director Coates general McMaster
most days the vice president as well
deliver the president most exquisite
information any leader in the world ever
gets a chance to see and is it still
contain those killer graphics you've
talked about it does
I love killer graphics so do you
communicate information right this is
this is the important thing it's
absolutely important that we deliver
information to the president in a way
that in the time that can be allotted to
this that he can grasp the central
information that we're trying to deliver
to him I met Mike Pompeo
Pompeo has cultivated a uniquely close
relationship with President Trump who
sometimes antagonistic tweets and
provocative post inaugural speech at the
CIA as you know I have a running war
with the media was said to put him at
odds with the agency something Pompeo
denies it was important to me that he
commander so I asked if you wouldn't on
his first day come out and talk to the
men and women of the CIA
that speech ended up being quite a
stem-winder though a heck of a day
our officers appreciated the president
coming after a very long evening the
paint before coming out to Langley to
speak with him and share his love for
them
your predecessor John Brennan had called
that speech a despicable display of self
aggrandizement when a former director
criticizes the administration what does
that do so there's a long history of
former directors behaving in a way that
reflects the excellence professionalism
and non-political nature of the Central
Intelligence Agency it is my hope that
all of the former directors will behave
that way because when they don't they do
damage to the CIA I appreciate the
opportunity to appear before you today
it was former director Brennan who told
Congress last year I saw information
intelligence that was worthy of
investigation that he alerted the FBI to
contacts between Russian officials and
the Trump campaign a central focus of
the ongoing investigation have you seen
any evidence of collusion with members
of the Trump campaign at the time I
wasn't on the campaign I haven't seen it
I can only I can only say this I've
watched this administration I deal with
all of our adversaries in a way that has
been robust in the CIA as part of that
is doing our part what is being done to
make sure that doesn't happen in 2018
and in the next presidential election in
2020 it's a great question Norah is a
very important question I can't answer
it I can only tell you this there is a
major push not only from the same but
all of this administration this
government to do everything we can to
prevent that from happening in 2018 in
2020 in 2030 and beyond it's been
reported though there hasn't been a
cabinet meeting about it there hasn't
been a National Security Council meeting
about it that's why you should follow
all the reporting you should take it all
with a grain of salt except yours not so
hot a percent so on that note is this
being taken seriously the Russian
interference in our dem
kradic process yes and I wish it had
been taken this seriously
previously while the former Republican
congressman from Kansas was no stranger
to Washington Pompeyo and his wife Susan
have sought inside her advice about life
at Langley
director Panetta gave me the advice he
said it's great we got two Italians
that's the same directors but also
helped me think about how to interact
with Congress right we have an oversight
body that funds the organization so he
gave me some ideas about how to make
sure that relationship was strong and
sound as well and Susan what did you
learn from this experience I'm sure
there are so many spouses people who
work here at the CIA right it's a whole
new world it really is and while I'm
able to meet with groups of spouses
which I tried to do regularly Mike
always is interested afterwards you know
how how'd it go would you learn and I
always say to him what I learned is you
should hire all of them because it turns
out that really smart capable bright
people marry really smart capable bright
people who are an amazing Patriots it's
a it's a family commitment like most
things are Pompeyo has swatted away
rumors that he's up for a role other
than this one and says he's focused on
changing things right where he is what
do you want your legacy here to be I you
know haven't thought about it I've only
been doing it for a year
I think our adversaries should know this
when Mike Pompeo leaves as the director
of the CIA this organization will be
more vicious more aggressive more
inclined to take risks to come directly
at the threats that America in the world
faces if I can do that I'll be very
proud of what I've accomplished during
my time as the director so what's
fascinating to get that inside look
about that a number of our topics
fascinating any seem very forthcoming as
much as he could be I mean I liked in
the last hour nor when you said did we
know about that latest attack and you
could tell he was thinking about his
answer but he then said to you yes then
when you asked a question that he didn't
want to answer he said great question
but I don't want to answer it I
appreciate yes candor just on that to
follow up on that because the the
reporting has been that our intelligence
on North Korea has not been the best and
that we did not know that that last
nuclear test was a hydrogen bomb and he
stated yes we
so that he hesitated a little the way he
the way he answered it but then he did
answer it yeah you talked about it some
at the CIA there has been talk about if
Rex Tillerson leaves state about him
potentially moving into that role at
some point does he say anything about
that I did ask him that specifically and
he said he's focused on his job at the
CIA so he has a good is it being a spy
but he did not give any clue about his
future role and he didn't say absolutely
not
he didn't say absolutely not that's very
interesting interview and misses his
wife too
yeah this is Pompeyo I thought added a
lot to that you always forget that a
spouse serves alongside so many many
enjoy whether it's in the military or an
administration so it's nice to see